apple is rethinking their entire iPhone
15 lineup next year and it's due to some
catastrophe in the current iPhone 14
lineup specifically with the iPhone 14
plus which is basically like the regular
iPhone but with a larger display and
apparently the sales have been so bad
that apple is seriously concerned about
releasing the iPhone 15 plus next year
in a similar way so they have to rethink
the entire lineup and something that it
might even get canceled altogether but
we just got a new report from a Korean
blogger saying that apple is rethinking
it in a couple of ways and they're
basically exploring two separate options
but before I get into revealing what
those two are I have to talk about why I
think the iPhone 14 plus failed so badly
so let's get right into it first of all
in my opinion they made a huge mistake
by delay playing the release of the
iPhone 14 plus because it was delayed
almost by a month so by the time it was
released a lot of people already
purchased one of the other 14 models so
the 14 plus was kind of lost in terms of
the hype and we even noticed that in our
own channel where the 14 plus videos did
not do as well in terms of the views
another big problem is the price it
starts at 900 and at that price you're
so close to the iPhone 14 pro and the
issue is that the pro model is just so
much better Apple has been doing an
excellent job by giving even more and
better features to the Pro Models and
marketing the pros much better as well
even down to just the naming Pro sounds
a lot better than plus but on top of
that one of the biggest things that came
to the Pro Models is the new Dynamic
Island which is seeing the notch finally
get removed after so many years since
the iPhone 10. so when you look at the
14 plus it has a notch and the notchless
dynamic Island Pro Models look just so
much better and more modern so paying
900 for a notched phone in 2022 is
extremely expensive especially when you
look at the other Android competition
which basically no longer have notches
on top of that with the 14 plus you're
stuck with only two cameras which means
that you don't get the telephoto camera
which could be very helpful like on the
Pro Models and this year's Pro Models
also got a brand new 48 megapixel camera
with Pro raw that looks absolutely
incredible so sharp and detailed and
you're missing out on that with the 14
plus now in my opinion there is another
reason which is basically the oncoming
recession where people are trying to
spend less money and budget more now the
interesting thing is that with the Pro
Models specifically the 14 pro Max which
outsold the rest of the models by far I
think with that model it's kind of tuned
towards the more wealthier clients where
they might not be impacted by the
recession as much so if somebody is
looking to buy one of the regular models
to save money they might as well just
get the 6.1 inch regular iPhone 14 for
800 instead of going up to that 900
price now another reason is that the
people who are buying the Pro Models are
more likely familiar with the tech
industry they know how to pre-order
their iPhone to get it quickly and the
people that are going for the regular
iPhone models more likely than not
they're probably going into a retail
store they pick it up they use it then
they try out the 14 plus and it feels
massive because they've been used to
these smaller phones that might be
another reason why they think it's not
worth spending another hundred dollars
on top for such a huge phone that might
be uncomfortable to use but then getting
even deeper another reason is that the
lineup is kind of confusing compared to
how it used to be before you would get
one iPhone every single year and then
with the iPhone 6 you would get a larger
iPhone 6 Plus so you had the choice
between two and then they set it up to
three with the iPhone 10r which was
budget focused now we have four ever
since the minis came online and the
minis didn't perform well but it looks
like the 14 plus is doing even worse so
with four iPhones in the lineup one of
them is bound to perform very badly
because you just have so many choices so
with that said in my opinion Apple
should just go back to three iPhones you
get the regular iPhone 15 then the 15
pro and pro Max or maybe even the 15
Ultra which is one of the scenarios that
apple is exploring according to the
Korean blogger apparently Apple could be
working on an iPhone 15 Ultra which will
basically be a a pro Max but with extra
features added on top that are better in
more different compared to the regular
pro model and that's going to be really
nice because it's called the 15 Ultra so
it sounds amazing just like the Apple
watch Ultra which did very well in sales
because it's 800 much more expensive but
it's a completely different design and
it sounds awesome so if Apple does that
with the 15 Ultra it's going to be a
very good seller and that'll likely make
the iPhone 15 plus if it does come out
even worse in terms of sales so that's
another option to differentiate between
the Pro Models and the lower end models
basically to make it maybe an even more
expensive model so maybe the Pro Models
and the ultra will be more expensive by
a hundred or even more dollars and then
in that case maybe it'll help the 15
plus do a little bit better because
there's a bigger price difference
between the 900 15 plus and the much
more expensive pro Pro Models coming
next year now the other option that the
Korean blogger gave was for Apple to
reduce the price of the 15 plus so
instead of 900 it would now be let's say
850 now that gives it a bigger
difference between the 15 plus at 850
and the Pro Models and maybe the ultra
so that might make it worth it to go for
that larger 15 plus and if you think
about it it's only going to be 50 more
expensive than the 15 so paying 50 bucks
for a much larger display and Battery
would it actually be a great idea and
very worth it now the hardest thing
about all of this is that Apple likely
had a lot of pressure in terms of profit
margins with the current iPhone 14
lineup and that is actually why I think
Apple kept the regular iPhone 14 with
the old a15 chip because that helped
them save some money and get higher
profit margins because in my opinion in
all of the issues with lockdowns and all
the protests in China and everything
else has made it more difficult to have
good profit margins because now they
have to pay more money to Foxconn
because Foxconn has to pay their workers
more money to stay there plus all the
supply chain issues with shipping prices
and everything else Apple likely was
pressured into giving the iPhone 14
models the older chip and I think that's
going to keep going forward into the
future but with all of this said and
wrapped up I think the best bet is for
apple to admit that they were wrong with
the 14 plus and next year make it more
simple so they can save some money just
give us the iPhone 15 for 800 and then
the pro and pro Max or Ultra that's
going to simplify the lineup and I think
it's going to help in terms of sales
with people being less confused and more
likely to go for that new Pro Max or
Ultra because that plus model is no no
longer there I think that's the best bet
for Apple to increase their revenues and
profit margins and average sale pricing
now if you think I'm totally wrong let
me know down in the comment section
below but if you enjoyed this video then
click the circle above to subscribe and
if you're interested in just buying one
of the iPhone 14 models I'll tag using
the YouTube product tagging feature down
below the model that I recommend right
now thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]
thank you